more than one thousand migrants camping
out in El Paso Texas as temperatures
there drop below freezing and migrant
shelters are overrun in the White House
they're focusing their efforts on suing
Arizona over their makeshift border wall
saying not only is Arizona refused to
hold its trespasses and remove the
shipping containers from federal lands
but it has indicated that it will
continue to trespass on federal lands
and install additional shipping
containers the United States brings this
action to obtain appropriate relief for
Arizona's unlawful continuing trespasses
wow former ice director and DHS Deputy
assistant secretary Jonathan Fahey joins
us now Jonathan can you believe a week
before title 42 is repealed that's when
the Biden Administration moves to Sioux
Arizona over building this border wall
what kind of timing is that
yeah yeah sadly I can believe it because
every single thing they do is to prevent
border enforcement and I want yeah you
do want to say it it's unbelievable that
they would do this but it really is so
predictable that any effort to enforce a
law will stand in the way of they'll
impede and remember this Administration
was just in front of the Supreme Court a
few weeks ago fighting to keep
aggravated felons in the country
fighting a law that told them to deport
them so they will do anything they can
to prevent enforcement because all they
want to do is encourage as much illegal
immigration as they can because they
want an open borders and later they want
Mass amnesty so it's really disgraceful
can you imagine the efforts going into
this if the efforts that these efforts
are actually going in to enforce the law
to make the lives of Americans better to
prevent drugs from coming in but they're
not this is what they're spending their
time on and it's really disgraceful and
the people in the trenches real lies
that and they are frustrated DHS
secretary Alejandro mayorkas reportedly
getting a not so warm welcome from
border agents during his visit to El
Paso earlier this week border patrol
agent telling the Washington examiner
quote when he stated he was here to
bring light to Suicide Prevention and
nothing about the migrant crisis our
staff couldn't believe it and made it
known to him another agent adding quote
they asked him why he's saying that the
border is secure when we have no agents
in the field he had the nerve to respond
that he never said the Border was Secure
Jonathan isn't it long past time for my
orchest to to go especially when he has
lost the people that he is supposed to
lead so badly
yeah he absolutely should not be in that
job but unfortunately this
Administration loves him because he is
doing everything he can to keep this
border open and and you see it right
there he's willing to lie to the people
he's responsible for leading that that
are entrusted under his care and he's
willing to look at them and lie and one
of the other things that was really
interesting about that article that I
read this morning was he talks about we
want to enforce the law consistent with
our values which basically is I I can't
think of anything more insulting to say
because the the implication is everyone
that's been enforcing the law is doing
something that's not consistent with our
values it's immoral and remember this
Administration just a year ago was lying
about border patrol agents accusing them
of whipping migrants and even after
they've been exposed as Liars they've
never come back and even acknowledged
that they lied about them and they're
still trying to punish those border
patrol agents the border patrol agents
have no reason to trust this
administration because they know this
Administration looks at them with utter
disdain and it's it can't be anything
more horrible than being in a position
they're in you know they talked about
morality and love they probably have no
morale whatsoever because they know this
Administration will look to harm them if
they do their job and it's really again
just so disgraceful yeah well Jonathan
more than a thousand migrants right now
they're camping outside in El Paso Texas
because all of the shelters are
overwhelmed where is the outrage over
the humanitarian crisis that's unfolding
there
yeah well again they do not care about
the humanitarian crisis they want as
much many illegal immigrants that come
to the country as possible they don't
care that they're being human trafficked
they don't care that this coincides with
massive amounts of drugs coming across
the border that will kill Americans they
don't care one bit about this and the
only time they're gonna we've even seen
them care about this was when they took
about 48 of them to Martha's Vineyard
then then they'll be up in arms and want
to do something but when they're in El
Paso or other states they could care
less and you're not going to hear
anything about it and if you take build
an illusion off the ground and Fox Fox
News the American people wouldn't even
know this is going on which is really
the another amazing aspect of this story
how the media is just it's unbelievable
listen I'm sleeping and curious Jonathan
thank you very much got to leave it
there Fox and Friends begins right now
bye-bye